so it is today the 18th anniversary of
9/11 it's incredible it has actually
been more than half of my life has been
lived after 9/11 then before 9/11 which
is incredible it's also incredible just
how fast time passes and with each
passing year since 9/11 since the
program has existed I have been
increasingly unsure I guess I would say
or kind of just ambivalent about what
should we be doing should we just be
doing the same thing every 9/11
anniversary more or less I don't know
it's actually been a few years since
we've even talked about it because for
the last several anniversaries I just
didn't really have anything new to add
so what I want to think about today is I
will retell the story of where I was on
9/11 which I remember vividly
although behavioral economists and
others would say my memory of this has
deteriorated over the years and it is no
longer accurate but you can go back and
check contrast with the first time I
told the story and then I also want to
talk about the sort of legacy of 9/11 is
I I now see it so on on the morning of
9/11 I was in high school and I was
sitting in psychology class with a
teacher of mine who I really like Donald
Palmisano who sadly is no longer with us
he actually passed away not that long
ago and I got the chance to see him out
in western Massachusetts at an event a
few years ago and I remember his wife
actually came up to me having heard my
description of my 9/11 morning and said
you know what when I heard you tell that
story I asked him is it do you think it
really went down that way and he said
you know I don't remember but it sounds
sort of like how it would go down so I
was sitting in psychology class and a
student who was sort of a regular
troublemaker whose name I forgot I think
his name might have been Erik and it's
amazing that his that the students name
I forgotten he was always out of a seat
and always walking around in the halls
he had gone to the bathroom and he came
back into the room
agitated an interrupted psychology class
and said to mr. Palmisano
we're under attack
happening in New York things are crazy
more or less just saying we were under
attack the country's under attack and
mr. palmesano looked at him in the
context of this is a guy who's always
interrupting class and sort of a
troublemaker and not particularly
well-behaved and just didn't believe it
and said you know what I'm sure
everything's fine please just sit down
and of course we later found out that it
was true and I don't think that there
was early dismissal but I certainly went
home and was just watching TV
the rest of the day and the following
day mr. Palmisano actually apologized
through the student and said you know
what you were right I apologize for how
I reacted and it's it's horrible what's
happened and we just had a conversation
in psychology class about what had gone
on since then with each passing year in
some senses our perspective on what took
place changes and evolves partially just
because when things are less recent our
point of view is altered I don't think
any of us can control this also
partially because we know more about
what the legacy has been and for me
unfortunately the legacy of 9/11 in the
United States has been pretty bad we
started a war in the wrong place as a
result of 9/11 against people who didn't
do the thing that we claimed was the
reason for starting the war we have seen
pervasive persistent and also
ineffective privacy invasions as a
result of 9/11 under the guise of
national security we've seen the Patriot
Act we've seen NSA surveillance all of
that stuff that we've talked about over
the last many years post 9/11 that the
David Pakman show has been going on we
have become really accustomed to the
persistent state of the global war on
terror the permanent war status quo of
we're always somewhere for many years
it's been Afghanistan a presence in Iraq
that never seems to end
other potential engagements all sort of
under this post 9/11 mentality of we've
got to make sure
that people out there who want to harm
us aren't able to do it and that we're
projecting strength and all of this
stuff one of the elements of the legacy
of 9/11 sort of the the high points not
in terms of them being morally good or
bad but just notable was the Obama
administration capture of Osama bin
Laden and then of course subsequently
everything we learned about the lead-up
to that and the people that were
involved we've seen a legacy of
continued ignorant and it's really more
than ignorance it's really more of a
deliberate kind of burying our heads in
the sand many of us about what creates
radicalism through foreign policy and
this is not you know very often when we
talk about foreign policy creating
radicals who want to attack the United
States it becomes a very sort of
Manichaean white/black thing of listen
either people are responsible for
choosing to attack the United States or
you're saying that they lack all
responsibility and it's just the fault
of the US through foreign policy for
radicalizing people and of course the
answer is no that's not the black and
white scenario that anyone who's
thoughtful is trying to lay out one of
the things we've hopefully learned over
the 18 years since 9/11 is that
radicalization both domestically and
geopolitically whether we're talking
about white supremacy or Islamic
extremism or whatever the case may be is
a combination of circumstances
domestically which are influenced by the
foreign policies of superpowers like the
United States combined with the
particular predispositions and sort of
circumstances of individuals all of the
white supremacists and former white
supremacists I've interviewed on the
show have told a very consistent story
about how they know who is sort of ripe
for radicalization and indoctrination
and in the same way when we talk about
al Qaeda or Isis or whatever we're not
excused
the actions of individuals when we say
we should consider the role that the
relationships between countries and
American foreign policy have on creating
an environment ripe for radicalization
while understanding that millions tens
of millions hundreds of millions
billions of people on the planet are not
apt to be radicalized regardless of
foreign policy these things are not
black and white and hopefully if there's
a positive legacy from 9/11 and I know
that for a lot of people this just
doesn't work but hopefully the more
thinking people are aware of this stuff
hopefully one of the positive legacies
of 9/11 if there's anything to find in
it is that we have sort of deepened our
understanding of the interaction between
personal circumstances personal
responsibility and geopolitical status
quo in creating radicalization around
the world we also have seen continued
neoconservative war hawking on a lot of
the right and even on some of the left
as a result of 9/11 in terms of even
justifying attempted or would-be
engagements in other parts of the world
over the last 18 years airport security
and the establishment of the TSA of
course a major legacy of 9/11 and
unfortunately not one of the best ones
TSA failing to identify banned items in
almost 95% of internal self-tests drills
so to speak of their security processes
so sadly it is mostly negative there was
I mean if we want to find something that
was sort of good that happened after
9/11 that of course doesn't outweigh any
of the bad there was actually a
short-lived positive sort of sense of
unity in the United States where hyper
partisanship was mitigated a little bit
and it was about coming together as a
country and helping people in New York
City and in Washington DC and all of the
people affected by 9/11 and it didn't
last long and it's not surprising that
it was these sort of black swan' type
events to take a term from Nassim Taleb
who has written about such events that
really kind of shook up the status quo
it didn't last very long and of course
then the administration of George W Bush
choosing to retaliate to 9/11 by going
into Iraq which had nothing to do with
it
did not help at all my question to you
how should we be remembering 9/11 as we
get closer and closer to 20 years out
from the event which is just incredible
that almost twenty years have gone by
and what do you see as the legacy of
9/11 on geopolitics on United States
foreign policy domestic issues and the
status quo I want to hear from you